[Musique]
on a beaucoup parlé de ses rêves et ses
réalités bien sûr on a beaucoup parlé et
chacun avec tellement de talent chacune
avec tellement de talent sur ses rêves
qui est est ce notre jeunesse et qui à
force de travail de talent de
persévérance de rencontres ça a été dit
ont réalisé des choses extraordinaires
dans leur vie et veulent embarquer les
autres c'est ça qui est important
maintenant vous êtes vous posé cette
question y at il des rêves partagés par
des hommes et des femmes le même rêve
s'ils ont pu changer le monde changer la
face du monde parce qu'il ya deux types
de rêve il ya ce qu'on vous dira tu
rêves c'est à dire que voilà on
s'échappe du monde on s'échappe des
contraintes en dés on va pas changer le
monde mais on veut s'en abstraire pour
des raisons de rêvasseries ou simplement
parce que on est stressé et on veut on
peut respirer sortir des contraintes et
puis à ses rêves évidemment ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui ce qui change le
monde et qui se concrétise maintenant on
va faire un petit expérience de pensée
les physiciens adam faire ça vous allait
fermer vos yeux s'il vous plaît et je
vous montre d'imaginer que vous êtes 70
mille ans je précise avant jésus-christ
est venu d'afrique vous êtes au bord de
la mer de timor est là devant vous c'est
80 km de mer l'inconnue absolue
l'horizon est à 40 km comme vous savez
là ouvrez les yeux
imaginez maintenant que des hommes des
femmes et des enfants vont décider ce
qui n'est jamais arrivé dans l'histoire
de la vie ils vont traverser la ligne de
wallace voilà c'était un ami de charles
darwin qui avait inventé la
biogéographique avait constaté que à
l'ouest de cette ligne il ya les
mammifères placentaires c'est à dire les
mammifères comme vous et moi chez
lesquels les femelles dans un utérus un
placenta et l'autre côté vous avez des
mammifères marsupiaux donc les
kangourous par exemple twilight s'est
jamais un ami faire place à terre
n'avait traversé et voilà qu'il ya au
moins soixante dix mille ans ces hommes
et ces femmes sont allées dans le
symbole qui réunissait à l'époque la
tasmanie
le str
oui la nouvelle guinée mais ils vont pas
s'arrêter là qu'est ce qui fait qu'ils
sont allés en océanie alors un jour
quelqu'un m'avait dit ah ouais il y
avait 80 km de mer jti c'est à l'époque
avait pas google maps donc l'océanie
avant les rêves exotiques de gauguin de
paul emile victor de jacques brel quand
vous y sont allés l'île de pâques cette
saison ne sont pas avec les cloches et
ça on ne sait pas alors nous autres les
scientifiques évidemment c'est normal
c'est notre job on essaye de trouver des
réponses
est ce que c'est la fin une famine une
crise volcanique qui ne manquent pas
dans les îles de la sonde
est-ce que c'est aussi des changements
climatiques bref d'état de pépin et ben
non ça ne marche pas parce qu'on ne va
pas vers l'inconnu
quand on a faim on essaie d'aller vers
quelque chose qui peut nous apporter à
manger les grandes migrations
aujourd'hui en europe là nous avons peur
de ces migrations qui nous évidemment
c'est jamais simple des flux migratoires
mais je rappelle quand même que le plus
grand flux migratoires dans l'histoire
de l'humanité
c'est nous les occidentaux parler dans
les nouveaux mondes way est donc là les
rêves d'amérique et un siècle mais on
savait haute et l'amérique avait de
l'espoir
c'était fantastique mais là l'inconnue
absolue sans savoir si on va revenir et
même d'ailleurs sans se poser la
question et bien les aborigènes ont un
nom pour ça
le temps du rêve le temps du rêve c'est
ce qu'ils expriment à travers la marche
et la sacralisation de leur espace skf
qui a été les cheminements leurs
ancêtres pour arriver donc aux peuples
d'aujourd'hui le temps du rêve alors ses
rêves évidemment ils ont changé beaucoup
de choses sur la terre christophe colomb
on arrive à la renaissance là alors on a
beaucoup ri n'a cité tout à l'heure la
création de la sorbonne mais en cas de
1530 sur le côté de la rue c'est le
collège de france donc on en pleine
renaissance est là donc c'est
l'ouverture vers de nouveaux mondes et
si mon ami erik orsenna qui m'avait
raconté
mais attends lorsqu'il a vu les très
catholique roi du portugal et d'espagne
pour engager son aventure et l'a pas
vendu
une technique j'ai des caravelles j'ai
des provisions je sais on va j'ai
déportant les ancêtres des cartes mots
il a vendu un rêve
il a dit que l'on leroy qui soutiendrait
ce projet serait un grand roi pour les
générations futures
les gros projets sont menés par des
rêves et à la renaissance
en plus des rêves des récits des
mythologies des religions et certains
arrivent à nouvel imaginaire les
imaginaires scientifique
imaginez vous soyez galilée et vous
soyez la première femme le premier homme
qui observe la lune et les anneaux de
saturne vous retournez la lunette c'est
là finalement petit blaise pascal
d'un seul coup s'interroge que sommes
nous nous les humains entre l'infiniment
petit et l'infiniment grand
donc les sciences ou s'ils vont ouvrir
les champs du rêve alors d'ailleurs cela
on conçoit bien qu'on est des rêves qui
nous porte delà de l'horizon
les aborigènes australiens enfin les
palais aux aborigènes australiens puis
stuff colombes tous âges d'accord mais
maintenant les autres rêvent les rêves
des temps perdu ceux d origine les
mondes perdus de caunes idol ce sera les
dinosaures se sera tout ça mais qui est
rouvert ce rêve
eh ben ça commençait par un rêve nous
sommes en 1831 un jeune homme sort
diplômé de cambridge très dilettante
assez brillant mais il n'a pas forcé son
talent il adore les sciences naturelles
d'ailleurs son père lui avait dit
quelques temps auparavant
mon fils tu seras la honte de la famille
tu ne t'occupes queue de rat de
cancrelats et de chasse alors néanmoins
il va faire de son fils un pasteur parce
que c'est la théologie naturelle et
c'est en étant que naturaliste admirer
l'oeuvre de la création alors là les
rives est pasteur c'est très honorable
c'est pal enthousiasme quand même et
l'hérault sur innelec 11 juin 1831 son
professeur john and slow professeur de
botanique à cambridge avec lequel ils
marchaient tous les soirs on disait
qu'il était l'homme l'étudiant qui
marchait avec john selon lui dit mon
jeune ami pour me propose une mission
sur un navire de sa royale majesté hms
beagle majesty chypre beagle mais je
suis trop âgé et je pense que vous avez
toutes les qualifications
ils exultent c'est charles darwin
évidemment il prend la lettre il va voir
son père robert darwin mais qui efface
staff a nommé normes et aux rites et
extraordinaire mais à mon père victorien
mais à mon père il lui dit non tu trouve
encore un prétexte pour éviter et
responsabilités
tu ne pars pas mais le disque devrait
dire tous les parents tous les
conseillers toutes les personnes qui ont
des jeunes enthousiastes autour de lui
cependant mon fils si tu trouves un
homme ou une femme à l'un des tonnes
d'hommes et de femmes qui consomment à
comps projet alors peut-être que j'irai
reconsidérer ma position
j'en la ruine pensons cheval ils
excellent cavalier il va voir son
adorable oncle josiah wedgewood ils
atteignent la calèche
ils font demi tour et darwin va partir
en septembre 2 831 et ce voyage va
changer le monde parce qu'il va ouvrir
le monde et diversité et le monde d
origine un siècle plus tard exactement
un jeune professeur de philosophie vient
d'être nommé au lycée de mont-de-marsan
weiss ennui c'est pas son truc
enfin il est brillant mais c'est parce
qu'il veut faire et l'aï reçu un coup de
téléphone de son ancien professeur de la
sorbonne
dis donc l'ami choix au sein toujours
intéressé par ave aux amérindiens
certes professeur certes bon écoutez il
ya un poste qu'il s'est libéré à sao
paulo
j'attends la réponse avant midi à tout à
l'heure tac c'est comme ça que les
préfets recevant par les relances élèves
alors je peux vous dire ils sont géniaux
les jeunes qu organiser cette réunion là
bas alors là pascal tu mon bâton texte
ou français qui serait un honneur
je parlais pas comme ça mes professeurs
un bon en tout cas c'est très
sympathique qui sont brillants vous avez
vu tout ce qu'ils ont organisés ils sont
extraordinaires c'est pas plus mal
en attendant en attendant moi eh ben oui
mais moi maintenant comment je suis venu
paléoanthropologue évidemment voilà moi
je vivais dans un terrain maraîcher
avant que lamont lieu n'existe si c'est
pas de la préhistoire ça et donc j'étais
donc mes parents étaient maraîchers à
gennevilliers moi j'ai connu ça à tout
faire et il travaillait c'était pas la
misère 1 c'était pas du tout ce que les
jeunes connaissent dans le 9-3 donc en
entendant parler tout à l'heure mais non
moi c'est un milieu c'était difficile et
voilà j'avais eu une enfance assez
solitaire pas beaucoup de contacts et
mais seul rêve c'était de tintin et
milou d'argent et j'avais un petit livre
de préhistoire
j'ai jamais envisagé d'en faire un
métier et puis voilà le monde a été
brutal pour nous ce qu'on appelle la
modernité c'est les films de jacques
tati
nous avons été expropriés et mes parents
ont compris que leur monde avait changé
ils ont dit à ma soeur et moi fait des
études lesquels il ne savait pas alors
ça tombait bien on appelle ça le lycée
moderne c'est à dire qu'on avait créé
des classes pour les crétins qui sortait
des classes populaires qui pouvait pas
faire du grec et du latin mais du sport
ça tombait bien ça me plaisait j'arrive
en troisième
et là j'avais un bon bulletin mais son
duo il effet ce fils de classe populaire
up enseignement technique
alors si à des briseurs de rêves c'est
les conseillers d'orientation
donc
à la giraille mécontent je peux vous
dire donc je vais au lycée ça se passe
bien je vais en physique théorique
métier sérieuses étaient repérables
physicien médecin sas est repérable
hockey et puis dans les années 70 grâce
aux médias évidemment essence et à venir
notamment on entend parler de monsieur
monsieur bernard van der meersch et les
néandertaliens tout ce que vous savez
sur leur talent par il ya 40 ans de ce
monsieur
professeur à pierre marie curie et puis
un autre qui commence à se faire
connaître il est tout jeune sympa yves
coppens avec cette idée piquée lui si
les australopithèques est vraiment ça me
tente mais vous savez qu'on sort d'un
milieu populaire
les métiers qui se termine en log enfin
bref les copains donc de physique me dit
fassi vas-y vas-y givet gens contre
bernard van der meersch un homme
extraordinaire vraiment un des tomes et
quand même j'avais un rêve ça je
commence à rentrer dans la
paléoanthropologie le rêve se construire
c'est arrivé assez tard quand même on
disait l'homme descend du singe
guilhaumon ça m'énerve
celui-ci c'est qui ce singe cela deux
villes s'étaient cachés se sache que je
me lève je saurais voir
alors depuis dix ans je les vois de
l'autre côté de l'uci alors évidemment
c'était yves coppens est mon patron qui
m'apprécient beaucoup rire à van der
meersch et l'honnêteté de dire c'est ce
qu'il veut il m'a soutenu donc dans ce
projet alors voilà la rencontre aviez
copains ce profil j'assiste en tant
qu'étudiant à une réunion la société
d'anthropologie de paris alors là je
peux vous dire c'est énorme énorme
société la plus ancienne d'anthropologie
dans le monde et la soirée s'est ternie
zone au mois de novembre
c'est l'ancien musée de l'homme la nuit
tombe il est 20 heures ambiance
belphégor ils truquent est là et tout le
monde s'en va battre van der meersch
s'excuse et il reste yves coppens et moi
même alors là je vais pas le contact
avec les professeurs comme les jeunes
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure en plus
yves coppens venait de rentrer à
l'académie des sciences est cher de pas
l'anthropologie préhistoire alors je
reste là quand même il 20h30
excuse-moi professeurs et d'un pétard
professeur van der meersch excuses et je
lui ai simplement vous donnez votre nom
je vais appeler le secrétariat et je
voudrais vous présenter mon sujet de
thèse et copains c'est que sa bonhomie
vous connaissez laiteries
je vous en prie asseyez vous et vous
savez pas le lendemain matin
moi le petit gardien j'avais dans ma
boîte aux lettres tous les livres et
tous les articles d'yves coppens et
voilà comment ça c'est fait alors bien
sûr j'avais un rêve s'était rencontré
les grands singes et hege contribue
évidemment à porter d'éthologie des
grands singes ou autre mais vous savez
pas quand on a des imaginaires comme ça
sur les grands singes et aux espèces
sénat ce coût se révèle nos origines
comme si c'était le sujet tabou ce n'est
qu'en darwin publie l'origine des
espèces au moyen de la sélection
naturelle l'origine c'était la théologie
cas soit de l'ordre de la théologie la
philosophie on ne touchait pas aux
origines c'est la métaphysique et darwin
aux en 1959 les origines peuvent être
investis par la science alors j mais dès
que je me suis engagé là dedans et
évidemment c'était mon rêve
alors qu'elle était aussi notre l'autre
chose a confirmé ce rêve
la fondation de la vocation la fondation
maintenant bleustein blanchet pour la
vocation ça existe depuis presque
quarante ans une machine à confirmer les
rêves une association d'hommes et de
femmes extraordinaires
alors j'ai été lauréat bien sûr il se
trouve que l'année dernière enfin un
petit peu avant la dernière promotion
porter mon nom j'en suis extrêmement
fier et ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on a des jeunes du monde entier de
tous les milieux
qu'ils soient riches ou pauvres qui
viennent d'afrique d'asie ou n'importe
où ce que l'on fait c'est soutenir leur
vocation et c'est ça la vocation c'est
passer du rêve à sa réalisation
et je vous donne deux exemples
une jeune femme année dans les plaines
de pologne dans un village très pauvre
avec anthropologue étudie les
amérindiens comme le lévi strauss alors
quel rapport entre les plaines de
pologne et les plaines d'amérique du
nord il ya des bisons laissez pas les
mêmes en pologne sont dans les forêts là
bas ils sont dans les plaines et bien
aujourd'hui à les anthropologues plus
dingue
un jeune homme dans un bled du côté de
dakar mais vraiment très pauvre
vous savez quoi il rêve d'être diplomate
alors même dans ce quartier c'est pas
gagné il reste des diplomates
et vous savez quoi les diplomates eh
bien depuis 40 ans presque blasé
messieurs 4000 lauréates et lauréats
il y en a pas
un qui a échoué dans sa vocation
aviateurs pianiste luthiste escrimeurs
etc et il faut pas grand chose pour
aider les gens à réaliser leurs rêves
quelles que soient leurs conditions on
parlait du 9-3 tout à l'heure avec hugo
un ami auquel il avait réussi ses études
et est vraiment dans des conditions
difficiles
il va à la boston university il dit je
veux renvoyer l'ascenseur il y avait une
classe préparatoire pour les écoles de
commerce on a parlé d' école de commerce
et il faut les aider et vous savez quoi
il a eu cette idée toute simple faire
venir quelques conférenciers comme why
do bien évidemment et en une seule
conférence ou deux d'un seul coup chaque
année on a vu le niveau d'intégration
montée comme les meilleures classes
préparatoires de paris alors moi j'ai eu
un petit coup de bol parce que il se
trouve que j'avais eu un portrait dans
libération est également j'étais passé
la veille à ce soir ou jamais bon c'est
pas très grave tout ça c'est pas très
importante mais pour ces jeux ça voulait
dire on nous envoie pas des seconds
couteaux
et vous savez quoi juste avant de venir
hier j'ai reçu un mail d'une jeune femme
qui dit écoutez j'ai assisté l'une de
vos conférences et al mahdi c'est grâce
à vous et vos amis que j'ai pu faire ce
métier deux heures par an c'est tout
comme incroyable ça
alors moi je suis fâché sur ces briseurs
de rêves qu'ils n'essaient pas pour toi
non tu rêves dans tes pas si riche c'est
bien sûr que tout le monde part pas avec
les mêmes chances
mais tout le monde a des rêves tout le
monde a des rêves et ça évidemment c'est
ça qu'il faut s'y mettre en place
alors maintenant quelles seront les
rêves pour limiter dès demain hugo nous
a dit effectivement c'est très bien
cette cartographie des des jeunes ils
sont nombreux sont dynamiques
franchement est les conférences qui font
là les jeunes ne le faisais pas quand
j'avais son âge là ils sont quand même
super bon et on voit toute cette qualité
cette jeunesse qui est là mais quelles
seront les rêves du futur et oui hugo à
raison pour la première fois depuis deux
siècles puis les lumières ensuite l'idée
de progrès et ensuite les trente
glorieuses avec les baby boomers cette
génération qui a eu une évolution comme
jamais dans l'histoire de l'humanité
car aussi beaucoup travaillé mais qu'a
fait aussi des bêtises et bien
aujourd'hui à la pression il n'ya plus
de projet de rêve pour demain les
grandes idéologies ne sont plus là alors
comment construire sur le monde de
demain
il est clair que les transhumanistes
essaye de strauss d'apporter des
solutions mais franchement ce n'est pas
très excitant
ça c'est le rêve californien la science
fiction c'est pas gai non plus ses
traits dystopique c'est à dire que
toutes les villes où les situations du
futur que l'on voit dans les films de
science fiction sont incroyablement
sinistre il n'y a pas de nature ces sont
des mégalopoles comme dans blade runner
et tout ça n'est pas très gai alors est
ce qu'on aura des machines qui nous
fabriquons des rêves
oui ça ça va être fait mais c'est pas
vos rêves comme dans le film
il s'appelle ghost in the shell vos
rêves sont les vôtres seconde jeunesse
outre genève ce que vous avez construit
comme le dirait mon ami boris cyrulnik
alors comme dans ce film blade runner
vous savez c'est inspiré d'un titre
génial de philip k dick qui s'appelle
est ce que les android vont rêver de
moutons électriques
c'est absolument génial parce que le
rêve du héros c'est d'avoir un vrai
mouton
c'est d'ailleurs c'est qu'est ce qu'une
société qui sera complètement
déconnectée de toute forme de nature et
c'est bien oui merci tout à l'heure vous
avez dit je m'intéresse aussi au monde
qui change et au monde qui vient et
comme j'étais physicien tout ce qui
touche à l'intelligence artificielle
m'intéresse beaucoup
et voilà ma fille est là j'ai des
petits-enfants et j'ai pas envie de
lâcher le morceau comme ça mais mes
rêves se sera pas les leurs est-ce que
j'étais un bon père ou par je ne sais
pas on verra mais en attendant je vois
quelque chose qui arrive aujourd'hui
elon musk nous promet mars oui mais
c'est pas tout le monde qui va y aller
et puis franchement qu'est-ce qu'on va
s'emmerder là haut l'autre chose est en
effet qu'est-ce qu'ils restent à
découvert sur cette terre les aborigènes
ont découvert de nouveaux nouveau
continent
les amérindiens aussi à leur manière ça
navigue depuis ce sens bilan et aux mots
des hommes l'espèce humaine
les espèces humaines sur très
particulière avant une bipédie on court
pas vite mais une endurance commet
aucune espèce ne peut avoir aucune
espèce même un cheval bien entraînés ne
peut pas nous tenir sur deux ou trois
jours bon entraînez vous entraînez vous
un peu puis choisissez de mon cheval
aussi mais nous avons une endurance
quand même assez exceptionnel
et puis nous avons ce cerveau au perche
il et nous avons sept vu ça les
philosophes l'ont bien vu bien
évidemment les anthropologues bien
évidemment et bien aujourd'hui il ya
tout un continent à explorer celui des
intelligences les intelligences des
animaux leur diversité les intelligences
de la nature aujourd'hui ce qu'on
appelle la machine learning diplôme ding
qui sont des appels la nouvelle
intelligence artificielle ce que pas
tout à fait vrai derrière mais
qu'importe nous permet d'explorer ce
nouveau monde
nous allons rentrer dans un monde d
intelligence que j'appelle
l'anthropologie des intelligences nous
allons pouvoir communiquer évidemment
arrêté animaux d'une manière plus
intelligente mais également aidé par les
alternatifs
ciel et être intelligent c'est quoi on
appelle ça chez nous les anthropologues
pour les singes notamment le cerveau
social être intelligent à rêver ses deux
contacts avec les autres c'est ça qui
est essentiel et donc n'ayez pas peur
des machines et attention ne sombrons
pas dans ce que j'appelle le syndrome de
la planète des singes ça c'est pas dans
les films
justement faut revenir à la littérature
à pierre boulle les rêves c'est quoi ces
les mots c les textes c'est les livres
comme disait mon ami cyrulnik à la
grande librairie
il est dommage qu'aujourd'hui le monde
se scinde entre ceux qui lisent et qui
construisent leur imaginaire sur des
textes et ceux et celles qui
malheureusement ne lis plus c'est ça qui
fait que nous sommes des homos qui
peuvent se projeter dans l'avenir
et alors dans ce monde qui vient avec
ses imaginaires
quel est le danger du syndrome la
planète des singes et dans le dcu dans
le chapitre 7 du livre de pierre boulle
ou là notre héros humain qui par là
parce que tout est sur le langage dans
la planète des singes ici on parle on
est humain ou singes ou l' inverse
et là ils ont chopé une femme est
extrait son disque dur une espèce de
psychanalyse hypnotique et aldi ceux ci
ont tout allait bien sur la planète
sport
nous avions des machines qui produisait
les biens nécessaires et nous avions les
grands sages domestique et qui
pourvoyait au service les plus attentifs
autour de nous mais au fil du temps nous
avons cessé d'être actif physiquement et
intellectuellement
même les huit enfants tan nous
intéressait plus et pendant ce temps ils
nous observait le danger ne viendra pas
des machines c'est pas terminator
le danger viendra du fait que par
confort par lassitude par feignantise
nous cessons d'être actif physiquement
et intellectuellement
alors je terminerai par un auteur que
j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle bruce
chatwin ces grands auteurs anglo-saxons
marcheurs et écrivain géniaux
explorateurs qui a écrit un très beau
livre s'appelle le champ des pistes et
se pose cette question mais au fait à
quoi sert un gros cerveau et il répond
pour marcher en chantant dans les airs
et moi je dire autre chose
à quoi sert notre bipédie extraordinaire
notre gros cerveau et nos rêves
et bien c'est justement à continuer
l'aventuré d'homo sapiens marché avec
vos rêves
[Applaudissements]